gentlemen you're here to compete in the
fifth battle of our gladiator of the
forge competition now jesse you have two
notches on your victory belt this could
potentially be your third win totaling
fifteen thousand dollars jesse weapon or
fortune one technique i want the
weapon
you know how this works what are you
thinking
the sick a sword
the sikka traces its origins back to the
first century where it was widely used
by thracian gladiators in the roman
coliseum
featuring a large hook double-edged
blade this deadly weapon was
specifically designed to reach around
shields to deliver cuts and slashes on
an enemy
while its unique curve made the sika a
formidable opponent in battle it proved
extremely challenging for bladesmiths to
replicate back in a season four
competition on forged and fire now eric
because jesse got to pick the weapon
that leaves you with the forge welding
technique what are you thinking
ladder pattern damascus ladder pattern
damascus all right now do you want to
have any minimum layer count
120.
there we go i love it
i'm going with the 120 layer ladder
pattern damascus because i'm comfortable
with damascus and i'm hoping that the
high layer count
might trip up my younger opponent
good luck gentlemen stay sharp your time
starts now
ladder pattern i'm not too concerned
about here's what he said after that
scared me
120 layers man why
that was a big bullet
[Music]
my first billet is 24 layers and my plan
is to get it drawn out and then cut it
up into five that would bring me to a
total of exactly 120 layers once i'm
certain that my walls are set i get
ready to draw out my belly i'm pressing
my billet down on the press and it seems
my welds were perfect
so i get my ladder pattern ground in and
then i flatten it out
and get ready to forge out my blade
there you go here we go
now that i've got my blade forged
completely to shape i get ready to he
treat my blade
jessie is questioning nice
i think we're good
it looks great i am feeling very solid
that's good
i sharpen it as best i can and it's time
to move on to the handle now that i have
the handle blocks glued onto my tang
it's time to put that mechanical
connection in my plan for the mechanical
connection is to put two pins one
through the actual handle block and one
through the pop-up
i put the pinhole through the handle
block and it goes very smoothly then i
move on to my pommel i shape the palm as
best i can and i bring it over to the
welder
i'm gonna make a weld bead so big it
acts as a nut
so that the pommel can't physically
slide off
this is a one-handed sword we're making
it can't be heavy so i'm starting with
14 layers of 15 and 20 and 10.95 welding
i'm going to have to cut it into three
restack it that will give me 42 layers
and then i'm going to have to cut it
into three and restack it again in order
to get to my 126 layers well that just
causing more work for eric because he's
gonna have to stretch out that steel
further stack it more and it's also
going to lose more material when he's
grinding all those pieces flat hopefully
i have enough
i get my second restack done
it's time to throw it in the oil
there it is all right all right eric has
quenched his blade i check it and i've
got myself a pretty darn straight blade
i'm ecstatic and then i realize i've
still got to do all of my handle work oh
my god he's gonna do a mortise handle
that seems like a very risky move he
knows he's got brittle handle material
and you guys are gonna put it through
the ringer
ain't pretty but it'll work
it goes through no problem and i am so
relieved
i still have to put an edge on this
blade but there's not a lot of time left
i get that curve as sharp as i can get
it hopefully it's sharp enough to cut
something but i suppose we're gonna find
out
five
four
three
two
one oh my god
turn off your machines put down your
tools this battle's officially over
blade smiths welcome to our strength
test our chariot wheel chop
jesse you're up first you're ready to go
ready to go
hmm
all right jesse nice job thank you no
edge damage everything's still straight
your handle a couple of little issues
obviously
you know having the wire of the mig
sticking out and i wish you had had time
to etch a little bit more so i could see
the pattern but i could see it and it is
there so all in all nice job thank you
all right eric you ready to go
yeah
good good good to know
i managed to make this small amount of
steel work but i am not a hundred
percent confident whether or not the
blade is gonna hold up in the strength
test
i'm hoping it holds together
all right breather
you survived man
nice job on the blade it's a little bit
of glinting but you still got an edge on
most of this blade
my biggest issue is the handle that
split on you
there's a lot of hot spots on there but
it didn't hurt me it's still straight
and still got an edge good job thank you
lady here's to the forge
welcome to the sharpness test the tube
precise
just here first you ready for this yep
all right let's do this
[Music]
all right jesse's talk about your syca
story here first stop
nice profile with your blade you have a
nice balance with the sikka
and overall sir
it will cut
thank you
eric your turns are you ready
cut them clean doug let's do this
all right eric let's talk about your
zika sword here it's a nice balance you
have with your weapon here now let's
talk about your edge in this area it's
just not sharp it probably took some
dulling during the strength test because
i can really run my hand on this but it
did cut a little bit and overall well
it'll cut a little bit
well gentlemen in eight hours you both
took stacks of steel turn them into 120
layer ladder to mass is sick cause guys
you impressed us the entire way through
but only one of you can come out on top
of this battle today earning a check for
five thousand dollars and the title of
gladiator the forge and the champion of
today's forging competition is
jesse you've done it again
congratulations eric man you fought hard
you impressed us all along the way but
unfortunately you're sick and did not
make the cut today i'm gonna have to ask
you to please step off the fourth floor
man go get him good job thanks guys
i proved everything to myself that i
came here to prove
this experience does make me want to
learn a bit more about some of the roman
weapons
there are multiple weapons on that wall
that i will be making in my future
jesse that's three up and three down now
you have fifteen thousand dollars and
you are two wins away from that bonus of
ten thousand dollars the big question we
have is
are you up for going back into battle
and fighting it out and trying to get
that 10 grand
yes
of course that was a little bit more
tentative yes than your previous
competitions
i'm still the reigning gladiator of the
forge that's my third win in a row and
that's fifteen thousand dollars we're
excited to see you fight it out again
man we'll see you on the coliseum floor
i'm gonna do my best to try to win as
many more as i can i want to go all the
way to the end
you